cette vidéo est sponsorisée par nextory
plus d'infos en fin d'épisodes on a
trouvé la vie sur Mars c'est un moment
historique qu'on est en train de vivre
c'est exactement ce que je dirais si on
avait trouvé de la vie sur Mars ce sera
un moment historique qu'on sera en train
de vivre pourquoi tu cries et toi
pourquoi tu cries parce que tu cries toi
pourquoi tu cries et toi pourquoi tu
cries parce que tu cries toi pourquoi tu
cries parce que tu cries et toi pourquoi
tu cries toi pourquoi tu cries cet
épisode va être long ah pardon superama
maman maman super ama super ma maman
maman
trop long il y a-t-il de la vie sur Mars
et bah on sait pas un peu comme la
dignité on la cherche encore mais cette
Titi sérieusement les scientifiques
depuis déjà deux siècles bah oui la
terre est mars sont si similaire sur six
temps de point de vue il y a des
calottes polaires des saisons peut-être
même de l'eau liquide en surface sauf
que plus aujourd'hui aller voir la vidéo
dédiée juste ici c'est jamais et aussi
les deux planètes sont plates pour
toutes ces raisons est bien plus encore
les chercheurs d'hier et d'aujourd'hui
se disent qu'après tout mars a peut-être
elle aussi choper des morpions et quel
morpion si on devait en faire un
portrait robot ça ressemblerait pas trop
à ceci mais plutôt à cela
non pardon des microbes unicellulaires
donc constitué d'une seule cellule comme
un sac de couchage qui contiendrait tous
les ingrédients pour faire tourner la
machine cellulaire attends c'est pour ça
que tu nous as fait venir dans ta vidéo
c'est comme ça je me casse
c'est quoi ça encore ma sœur jumelle
morte c'est impossible elle est juste
comment elle a fait tu as froissé le
tissu de l'espace-temps à téléporter
Valentine ici pour ta blague en
introduction qui n'était même pas assez
drôle ah mais du coup j'ai emmené Fiona
avec
et du coup tu tiens beaucoup ou pas
parce que sinon on l'attache discret
dans l'espace pas question elle est sous
ta responsabilité maintenant c'est toi
qui t'en occupes
[Musique]
sur Mars les conditions de vie sont
tellement hardcore que s'il y a de la
vie ben elle est plus forte que ma
capacité à finir une phrase rien que le
fait que la planète n'est plus de champ
magnétique ça expose sa surface au
rayonnement l'étau du soleil
ces rayons c'est la mort des cellules ça
dégrade carrément l'ADN et l'ARN en 2007
des chercheurs ont même calculé que s'il
y a de la vie sur la planète rouge et
bah pour se protéger des rayons elle
s'est forcément réfugiée à au moins 7,5
mètres sous terre enfin sous mars du
coup la vie on la cherche plutôt dans le
sol c'est pour ça que dans les années 70
la NASA a envoyé deux atterrisseurs sur
Marseille le programme Viking comprenez
4 expériences seul l'une d'entre elles a
fourni un résultat apparemment positif
l'expérience consistait à prélever un
morceau de sol martien le maître sous
cloche en l'arrosant de lumière pour
simuler le soleil et de gaz carbonique
tracés radioactivement pour pouvoir
suivre où il va et alors surprise le gaz
carbonique a été absorbé par le sol
comme l'aurait fait des plantes elle
sait dire qu'il y avait des organismes
photosynthétiques dans le sol c'est ce
que ce sont demandé les têtes d'ampoules
pendant un moment mais aujourd'hui la
majorité des scientifiques pensent que
mon prompteur est trop lent mais
aujourd'hui la majorité des
scientifiques pense qu'il y a pas besoin
de vie pour absorber du gaz carbonique
il y a plein de processus chimiques tout
bêtes qui pourraient faire la même chose
de plus les analyses de la composition
du sol martien non décelé aucun composé
ce qu'on associe généralement à la vie
donc à part deux trois rigolos qui n'ont
pas avalé la pilule la communauté
scientifique est d'accord pour dire que
les sons de vikings n'ont pas trouvé de
traces de vie sur Mars et aucune des
sons suivantes non plus d'ailleurs
moralité pour ne pas avoir de trace de
vie vaut mieux avaler la pilule ou
utiliser un cintre si vous vivez au
Texas n'oubliez pas les enfants ainsi
oublier les enfants même si il y a bien
eu cette histoire de tâches sombres tu
parles de mon ronflement bras on les
connaît depuis 98 les tâches sombres
sont des tâches grises de 15 à 45 mètres
de diamètre or non la calotte polaire
Opel sud de mars elles apparaissent au
début du printemps et disparaissent
avant le début de l'hiver est-ce que là
comme c'est l'été elles sont dilatées
comme jamais d'ailleurs avec ces tâches
on croise généralement ces structures là
on les appelle des araignées martiennes
les scientifiques ne savent pas
exactement ce que c'est tous ces machins
pour la NASA il s'agirait de poussière
ou de cendres basaltiques associées à la
présence d'hypothétiques geyser de CO2
au printemps mais des chercheurs
hongrois se demandent si ce serait-il
pas des colonies de bactéries de type
extremophiles qui résistent à tout des
bactéries photosynthétiques qui se
nourrissent du soleil printanier sous la
couche de glace qui du coup serait
visible en gris quand cette couche de
glace s'amincit quand toute la glace
au-dessus d'elle disparaît les bactéries
deviendraient toutes sèches et toutes
noires comme des pruneaux c'est une
hypothèse intéressante maintenant
faudrait peut-être envoyer une sonde
là-bas pour voir à quoi ça ressemble
dans ton renflement brun ce que j'ai une
vidéo de coloscopie qui suggère que
c'est pas joli joli
l'autre chercheur souligne qu'en fondant
la glace pourraient créer des poches
d'eau liquide qui serait susceptibles
d'accueillir des microbes ou alors des
plantes très très simples tout ça ça
reste à confirmer bien évidemment on en
est au stade très fragile des histoires
que les scientifiques se racontent au
coin du feu de toute façon il est utile
de le rappeler aucune mission martienne
n'a encore trouvé la moindre preuve de
vie même si on pourrait très bien être
passer à côté et les conditions qui
règnent aujourd'hui à la surface de la
planète sont vraiment pas propices au
développement de la vie telle qu'on la
connaît même si dans le doute en
stérilise quand même les Rover et autres
fantasy qu'on y envoie chose qu'on
devrait faire avec les platistes qui
n'avale pas la pilule
surtout quand on s'attaque à la vie sur
Mars
[Musique]
donc non seulement le portrait robot
d'un martien ressemblerait plutôt à ça
mais en plus il serait en noir et blanc
pour économiser l'encre j'ai eu la
flemme de le colorier parce que ce qu'on
cherche vraiment sur Mars c'est des
fossiles vu que y trouver de la vie
actuelle bah ça paraît légèrement
compromis mais j'aime ton état d'esprit
l'écologie ça me parle du PQ bon je suis
Fiona donc sur Mars plus que des
fossiles on cherche des bio signatures
c'est pas des bafouilles écrites avec de
l'encre de graines de chia sans gluten
mais n'importe quelle trace laissée par
une forme de vie des fossiles du caca du
vomi du pipi des molécules organiques
complexes des molécules symétriques dont
une forme serait plus abondante que
l'autre des anomalies isotopiques la vie
préfère les versions les plus légères
des atomes du coup dans des traces
biologiques on aura un excès de ces
isotopes légers bref on peut chercher
pas mal d'indices à condition bien sûr
qu'ils aient pas été détruits par les
rayonnements solaires entre-temps
aujourd'hui on l'a vu l'environnement
Marseille est trop hostile pour espérer
y trouver de la vie autochtone en tout
cas ça paraît vraiment difficile mais un
peu comme le racisme décomplexé c'était
mieux au nom de chien entre 4,1 et 3,7
milliards d'années avant Jordy le climat
était plus clément et le noyau de mars
est encore assez actif pour générer un
champ magn qui la protégeait des
rayonnements solaires la rumeur dit
qu'il y avait même probablement de l'eau
liquide en surface rapport au valet et
aux sédiments martiens qui datent tous
de cette période et même des schnops un
genre de nouvelles marques de céréales
schnops humains c'est un acronyme
désignant les six éléments chimiques
principaux qui constituent les êtres
vivants le carbone l'hydrogène l'azote
l'oxygène le phosphore et le soufre elle
constitue les briques élémentaires
nécessaires au développement de la vie
tel qu'on la connaît sur terre
mais du coup ça se mange ou pas
curiosity avec des molécules organiques
complexes dans des sédiments du Noah
chien non seulement les roches de
l'époque abritent les briques pour
construire l'édifice du vivant mais en
plus cette période propice concomite
avec l'apparition de la vie sur terre
puisque le Noah chien s'étend de 4,1 à
3,7 milliards d'années on l'a dit et que
les premières formes de vie sur Terre
identifiées formellement sont vieilles
de 3,8 milliards d'années quand incident
peut être en vrai on en sait rien du
coup on pourrait très bien imaginer
qu'une météorite venue de mars ait pu en
ce moment c'est la terre avec des formes
de vie martienne et réciproquement on en
connaît quelques-unes des météorites
martiennes tombées sur terre donc ce
serait pas aberrant et en plus ça ferait
écho à cette histoire de pense permis eh
oh ma monétisation t'approche pas de
cette flûte de Pan la panse permit est
une hypothèse apparue au cours de
l'antiquité selon laquelle l'origine des
organismes vivants sur Terre serait une
contamination extraterrestre source 1 2
3 5 6 ah mais depuis tout ce temps tu
lis Wikipédia en fait et donc si ça se
trouve la vie est apparue en mars par
exemple dans des sources chaudes comme
on en trouve sur terre Spirit on a
trouvé une dans un plateau de 100 mètres
de diamètre que les Américains ont
baptisé homeplate en référence au
baseball moi non plus j'ai pas la relève
absolument spirity a observé des
minéraux hydratés et des dépôts
volcaniques qui d'après leur nature et
leur composition chimique ce serait
formé au contact de l'eau liquide
attends mais tu viens de woman spleen en
anecdote là il a même trouvé des nodules
d'Opale en plus dans ton pense qu'ils
sont nés dans un contexte hydrothermal
c'est à dire dans une source d'eau
chaude et acide je t'ai eu un tu veux
bien éviter de me man's planner s'il te
plaît les chercheurs pensent que
homeplate est un ancien Fumerol un
panache de vapeur qui s'échappe du sol
dans une zone volcanique active fragile
ça tombe bien que tu parles de
météorites j'en parlais pas du tout
j'arrive pas à me placer une depuis 20
minutes ce que c'est aussi là qu'on a
essayé de trouver des traces de vie
martienne bah oui c'est un caillou
martien atterrit chez nous et qui a des
Zinzins de l'Espace dessus alors Manu
Dibango les Marseillais existent et
Orson Welles c'est Raël avec tous les
deux raisons il y a même quelques
météorites qui ont défrayé la chronique
par le passé de naguère notamment à
lh8401 je la connais bien celle-là j'ai
eu un semestre de cours sur elle à la
fac ils étaient trop cool il s'en fout
al-h84001 ou Alan Hills 8 4
001 est un fragment de météorite
découverte en 1984 dans les collines
d'Alan en Antarctique le caillou est
devenu une rockstar dans les années 90
quand des chercheurs de la NASA ont
passé au peigne fin du mini-croscope et
on découvert ceci des bactéries mieux
des grandes magnétiques alignées comme
les structures qu'on trouve dans
certaines bactéries qui s'orientent
grâce aux champs magnétiques sur terre
et c'est à dire qu'il s'agirait donc de
traces de vie martienne retrouvée sur un
vaisseau spatial minéral les chercheurs
ont trouvé un autre élément remarquable
sur cette météorite Xavier Dupont de
Gonesse non parce que ça fait un moment
qu'on le cherche
les hydrocarbures aromatiques
polycycliques sont un groupe de composés
organiques généralement considérés comme
des marqueurs d'activité biologiques ils
ont aussi trouvé des acides aminés des
composés organiques qu'on associe
souvent à la vie donc quand nous
cherchons annonce et surtout les médias
en fait les mecs on a trouvé des restes
de bactéries martiennes et de leur repas
vous imaginez bien quel genre des mois
ça a pu susciter mais au-delà de les
mois ça aussi générer une controverse
d'une violence sans nom ne l'appellerons
Thérèse et oui parce que les
scientifiques aussi étaient fébril si
c'est vrai c'est énorme sauf que des
analyses ultérieures ont montré que
c'était très probablement du flan
d'abord d'autres chercheurs ont montré
que ce genre de composés peut aussi se
former chimiquement sans qui est d'être
vivant dans l'affaire organique ne veut
pas forcément dire produit par un truc
qui respire ça veut juste dire qu'il y a
du carbone dedans même si quand on
arrive à des molécules organiques
réflexe des débours rubans ou des
chouettes colliers là il y a sans doute
quand même un être vivant qui nous a
tricoté tout ça et pas ailleurs j'ai une
grosse bouée il peut aussi s'agir d'une
contamination terrestre la météorite est
tombée sur terre il y a 13000 ans en
attendant qu'on la ramasse et la puce
faire grimper dessus par des organismes
vivants des plus petits au plus gros moi
aussi j'attends de me faire grimper
dessus j'adore l'escalade c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui est arrivé à une autre
météorite celle de tatawin comme la
planète dans Star Trek on y avait
retrouvé une bactérie ramener bacters
tata winnensis sauf qu'en fait il y en
avait autour du site la météorite avait
été ramassé donc c'est sans doute pas
des microbes martiens juste terrestre
pareil pour élève 84 01 même si on
aurait tous préférés que ça se termine
autrement
et on lui souhaite d'ailleurs un bon
courage et salut c'est saturax au fait
en parlant de trucs qui tue ça me
rappelle un truc c'est le thème de la
princesse Leia dans Stargate avec ses
deux accords ré majeurs et donc à ce
jour on a toujours pas trouvé de vie sur
Mars ni actuel ni passer pardon si je
dérange mais j'avais juste pas terminé
ma phrase avec tout ça faut pas oublier
qu'on a un léger biais anthropocentrique
on cherche la vie telle qu'on la connaît
sur terre si ça se trouve l'hypothétique
vie martienne s'est développée sur des
éléments des mécanismes différents des
nôtres mais en attendant faut bien
partir de quelque part hein faut bien
partir
faut partir maintenant et rechercher la
vie sur Mars c'est aussi glaner des
indices sur comment elle a pu apparaître
sur terre moralité il y a probablement
pas de vie actuelle sur la planète rouge
vu comme les conditions ils sont
hostiles et ce dès à l'époque
géologiques qui a suivi le Noah chien
c'est à la fin du nom hien que Mars
aurait perdu son champ magnétique et ce
serait fait bombarder tel la bande de
Gaza par les rayonnements solaires et
son climat serait devenu nettement moins
accueillant mais ça ne nous empêche pas
d'y chercher de la vie fossile
inch'Allah on en saura plus avec le
programme ExoMars qui va justement
chercher d'éventuelles biosignatures
dans le sol martien comme Viking en son
temps mais en mieux lui il sera
notamment équipé d'une foreuse qui
pourra prélever des roches à plusieurs
centimètres sous la surface voir si on
pourrait y trouver des traces de vie
fossiles bien à l'abri des rayons du
soleil à faire à suivre
[Musique]
une salle que lui
sur le site
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et ce crédit les choses
[Musique]
et faire un corps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci à nextory de soutenir cette chaîne
next Story c'est une application de
lecture et c'est même la seule en France
qui propose tous les formats des ebooks
des BD des livres audio des séries audio
ex-occlusives des podcasts des magazines
de la presse écrite au lala c'est un peu
pratique d'avoir tout réuni au même
endroit le catalogue regroupe plus de
250 000 titres pour tous les goûts de la
romance du fuela de la science-fiction
des recettes de cuisine des guides de
voyage de la science je m'en sers
beaucoup dans le train comme j'y passe
une partie non négligeable de ma vie
j'en ai profité pour me refaire des
grands classiques en livre audio c'est
vraiment chiadé et très agréable à
écouter ça permet aussi de vous
documenter sur votre sujet préféré ou au
contraire d'aller explorer des choses
que vous n'auriez jamais été lire sinon
on en ressort toujours grandi en plus il
y en a pour tous les âges vous pouvez
aller écouter des histoires avec vos
pitchouns ça permet de développer leur
imagination l'appli nextory est en
formidable elle est disponible sur
smartphone tablette et ordinateur ça
fonctionne par forfait mensuel vous avez
trois forfaits différents pour s'adapter
à vos besoins et comme je suis quelqu'un
de très généreux et pas du tout
intéressé car je touche une commission
sur vos abonnements je vous offre une
période d'essai de 45 jours sur la
formule standard grâce à mon lien
affilié à retrouver en description de la
vidéo allez donc vous culturez sur
nextory vous m'en direz des nouvelles
merci à super amai saturax pour cette
super collab n'hésitez pas à aller voir
leur chaîne quels sont bien et abondance
vous la cloche merci aussi aux copains
pour les covers on espère que cette
vidéo vous aura pas des plus l'épisode
s'appuie beaucoup sur ce livre en avant
mars de Nicolas Beck Sylvain breton et
Jessica Flahaut aux éditions je vous le
recommande il résume un peu tout ce
qu'il y a à savoir sur Mars de manière
très accessible et agréable et je
précise que c'est pas un placement de
produit rémunéré
[Musique]